it's been harder for Trump to find
people to perform in his inauguration
than it is to find people to perform in
his administration a number of acts of
refuse or outright canceled and those
who are performing or gearing up for
what will probably be their last ever
appearance on stage see it he'll three
doors down there's actually a picture of
the 70s band Three Dog Night but we
don't know what three doors down looks
like we just that's what we had but the
Reformers that do sign up for that
moment in the freezing January Sun will
probably be treated like royalty for a
few minutes so comedians I want to give
me some items or demands you might find
on a Trump inaugural performers
backstage writer agreement Dave Anthony
the ability to feel shame all right boys
Hossein crisp white sheets all right
points 70 some Mexican food with a wall
built around it all right boys the same
a fourth door down all right Anthony a
bullet grab a box all right boy seven
eight a gift basket of ammo and Keystone
like a scientist so you can burn him
with cigarettes Stephanie a copy of the
Constitution and someone who can read
good and mr. Brian Posehn a dumb red hat
with a stupid thing on it